how old were you seven this is like mark
saw your stuff so at the age of seven
i've already done what i'm doing today
and figuring it out how do i do this
better
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community
fund in silicon valley in partnership
with leumitech
sponsored by hippo insurance opposed
labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctec
thank you for joining me on another
episode of 20 minute leaders today i
have the unique
and amazing pleasure of sitting with tal
jacobson general manager at code fuel
tal is an executive in the israeli
high-tech industry for over 20 years
he was the chief revenue and business
development officer at similarweb who
recently went public
tal also held leadership positions as
the vice president of business at mccann
ericsson
and was part of the business development
team at icq and aol
tal is now the general manager at code
fuel the search technology division
of period network welcome tal
jacobson welcome to 20-minute leaders it
is so great to have you with me today
oh great thanks for having me i'm
excited to have you are you
calling from the code fuel offices right
now
yeah yeah with the israeli offices
of course fuel general manager at
code fuel but you know i'll start with
this
er when i asked you before because your
your resume is too big
to even start to understand where we're
going to start asking what is most
exciting for you and and i loved your
response because you said
you know the journey was a lot and
there's a lot of twists and turns and a
lot of unexpectedness and that is
exactly what i love talking about in
this show and so
you know just as a small highlight you
know you were
chief revenue officer and chief business
officer at uh
at similar web at uvp at mccann ericsson
digital
at entrepreneur residents and tech stars
and
today you're at code fuel and there's a
lot of things in between that i didn't
even mention
because my my memory is not as good as
the list of your of your experiences
but i want to ask you tal going back to
your times and as an animator i can't
believe that's where we're
starting yeah how the hell do you get to
be an executive in some of the most
amazing companies
in israel and the world how does that
happen
uh so we i think it all happened by
mistake
uh like all good things uh
i started by pursuing what
i love to do which is drawing and doing
animations
i started like 25
years ago 26 years ago learned animation
went to the us work
a bit in animation then i had to come to
israel
ran out of money i couldn't get back to
the united states
find a company who would hire me that i
knew their software which was macromedia
the company who
invented flash and was bought by adobe
i i thought i was gonna work there for
three months
save some money go get back one thing
led to another
been there for six years the company
went to
4 000 employees uh i became
a vp marketing of this region
i have no idea how that happened but uh
was quite a journey
at the end of it it was bought by adobe
so
i really got into this high-tech
business
executive kind of thing uh by mistake
and so as you if if you look back at
your journey now
what what is the what is the common
thread so you've held
executive positions at a few big
companies already
what has been a common thread as you as
you journeyed along these different
experiences you mentioned over 25 years
yeah when what i really am asking is who
is tal who who is tal
uh so i think the common thing is
how do you get to a
place and solve the issues that they
have
so for example in macromedia
bear in mind 25 years ago well i'm so
old
so in macromedia we wanted to sell you
know software but back then
we sold boxes of software with cds and
books right
wasn't what we have today
and uh i came up with the idea of doing
performance marketing
where performance marketing wasn't that
common and we've did
we've done that by fax
so we got all the numbers from all the
studios
who would buy this software and
overnight we've sent
a brochure to all those companies and in
the morning
our sales team were bombed with phones
and we've sold so many software by fax
which was the first uh performance
marketing and
and with you know throughout the years i
went and
teach mba students
marketing and i said you know it doesn't
matter if you're doing that
online or you're doing billboards as
long as you can define
your target audience and know how to get
them
uh then everything's the same nothing
changed
you just need to find the right channel
now what what drew you to the world of
marketing in the first place and perform
and
and we'll talk a little bit about
performance marketing but in the in the
idea of marketing what drew you there
and from the get-go
uh so i think you know
looking back the thing that drew me
to animation was creativity in
marketing and problem solving has the
same thing
right you know you need to figure
something out
and you need to be very creative how do
i
get to that place through
a way that nobody else thought right
normally when you want to generate the
higher roi you need to figure out
something that nobody else
thought about so
creativity problem solving you know
that's really all about um what drives
me
right and so today general manager at
code fuel
and tell me a little bit about what that
role is for you
because one of the things that i'm
always curious about is
why do people decide to do what they do
and now with the record that you're
coming with
arguably you could really pick and
choose whatever position you'd want in
any company and
and i'm really curious what what is it
about code fuel and this
and this the job of a general manager
that
specifically spoke to you right
um so you know quote fuel
is the search division of perio network
which is
a publicly traded company in the nasdaq
and prairie young just
uh the parent company of kuzvil had a
new ceo come
that came on board dawn got stand
and when he spoke with me about the
company
and his vision and what we can do about
it
and then i looked at you know the stock
price
and what cultural does and i said you
know what
there's a real opportunity here to to
change the thing
change everything and when you look at
the stock
in the past two and a half years that
i'm here at least
uh we really changed how the company
works
you know we became the biggest partner
of microsoft
uh stuck went up really uh you know from
like
we were worth seventy thousand seventy
million dollars now we're
uh 550 in in two years
wow uh you know touchwood
um but it's all about you know
i always says you know uh guy kawasaki
said that once
and it really uh
i really think that's that's the way you
know i always say that
i have the golden touch and when
people's when i said that everybody
looks kind of weird and i said it's not
that everything i touch
turns into gold i just need to find gold
and touch it
so i look for companies that are like a
diamond in the rough
like companies that i know they have
good potential
but they didn't get to where they need
to get
and that's where my skill problem
solving uh
gets in i had the same kind of thing
with similar web
yes so similar web you know they offered
me the job at 2008
and which was early days for similar web
with
or and i think you know
war is amazing but back in 2008 the
product was totally different i didn't
believe in the product
um a few years ahead
2012 or gave me a call
said you know what we're doing a pivot
something totally different
you know just come look at what we do
let me know if you want to be part of
that
i came to the office i look at the data
and i told or you know what
this is awesome i want to use that data
i don't care if it'll work here or not
i want that data yeah so i'm going to
join no matter what
so you know finding things that you
really believe in
that you know there's a huge potential
that nobody
um that with your skill you can turn
into gold
that's that's the golden touch find
things that your
touch can can turn into gold because
the gold is there you just need to to to
take it
so going off of that and looking at the
different positions you've held and the
you know important strategic positions
that you know at the end
led to you know decisions being made and
outcomes you're talking about golden
touches
but tangibly how do you then go about
your your day
thinking through you know what how to
how to actually make those strategic
decisions when you look back
you know as you're now in code fuel what
lessons have you learned through the
other experiences that enable you
to to do your job well now
uh i think you know the major lesson
here
uh that i learned throughout the years
that
you know ideas come and go the ideas
don't have any potential
it's only people so
i try to find
people that i i believe in so perry and
ceo
dawon is an amazing person to work with
that's
you know that was the main think that
you really hear
uh you know working with the ore at
similar web
you know you can see the quality you can
see that no matter what
he would he would make it right and at
the end of the day
you know that right when you invest in
people you don't invest in ideas you
invest in people because ideas
constantly
shift right uh
and you want you want to find people who
are going to be you know your
co-founders to the
to the journey when things you know go
go sideway
and things always go sideway you want to
find your partners right
and and that's that's the goal that's
that's the key
so looking at specifically i'm curious
about to say this
question of chief revenue or chief
business or or any position that that
has to do with you know thinking about
revenue streams thinking about the
growth of the company
you know either specifically in similar
web or or elsewhere
what does it actually entail so what
what are the questions that you're
asking yourself on a daily basis that
you're concerning yourself with and how
how far along do you have to think
as you're making those decisions
um how far along so
listen i'm a performance kind of guy i'm
all about execution so
you know i have a five year strategy but
if it doesn't make money
two months from now it's not worth it
and why is that so why is it why is it
not worth it if in two months it doesn't
make money
right um so you know i'll take it back
not only money but you need to you need
to think big
like really big where am i going to be
where the company is going to be in
three years from now
and then you need to break it into the
smallest pieces that you can
so you can constantly validate
that you're that you're on the right
path
to the bigger dream so if you mean if in
two or three months
you're not on the right path you either
change the path
or you need to re evaluate your dream
or your goal or your strategy but you
can't
before you said money was more of a
metaphor for a a signature of
improvement a signal that you're moving
in the right direction
and what i'm hearing from you is that
even though you you think you know maybe
five years ahead
you need to pick to make decisions that
are going to
in the short term validate the path
towards that
you know and that end goal and if you
can't validate within
a very short time span then it might not
be worth it because you don't know
whether you're
even going in the right direction right
right
right so you know for me money is like
points in a game you need to you need to
earn those points
otherwise you might not even playing
even though you're working very hard but
you're not playing the right game
so those are validation points right and
so
if i ask you today what is it that you
that really gets you up in the morning
that really you know you wake up and say
ah i love what i do
and not the title but in the actual day
today what what is it what is what is
part of your work that you really
you know that's your core
so again i think problem solving
in huge scales that's what i like to do
give me a huge problem that i can see
the progress this is why i need it to be
very
tangible you need to be very measurable
otherwise i can't i don't understand if
i if i made any progress or not
right so give me a huge problem
and let me measure it that's
that's really what drives me right
now i i guess i'm asking but i i have a
feeling i know the answer if you look
back to your times as an animator
do you see yourself where you are today
and you've had well
you know what i think what i do now
is what i always done so
somebody asked me when was my first job
like a month ago and i remember like a
funny story that i totally forgot to put
up until
at that point when i was seven
that was my first job
i went to the grocery store and i told
the manager there
i'm gonna do all the errands and you're
gonna pay me
i remember what what it was then but
maybe like five or ten
you know israeli shekels and
i've i've done that for a day or two
and after i day or two i figured out i
can ask my friend to do all the errands
and i can give him half of the money how
old were you
seven this is like mark i saw your stuff
so at the age of seven i've already done
what i'm doing today
figuring out how do i do this better how
do i scale
and you know both my parents are like
that
so i guess you know doing animation is
great
and i'm you know i have this creative
side
but you know solving issues solving
problems figuring out how do i make this
better how do i make this uh scalable
is is a way of it's a way of thinking i
guess
i don't you know i was born like that so
on more of a leadership perspective
you've
been managing people for a long time
across the different organizations
what what's the same what types of
things
do you see coming up often whether it
comes to hiring
or day-to-day management of people or or
running an innovative approach
what what what is you know similar but
maybe not
trivial that maybe i as young
entrepreneurs
still don't understand because i haven't
experienced it yet for myself
right um
so for me the key here and that went you
know i saw that
over and over at companies always
hire people that
you know you can mentor them but
they need to do their job better than
you
and treat them as co-founders
don't treat them as employees like make
them
partners to the journey and
with all the people that work with me
every meeting
starts by me asking okay what do you
need from me
because i'm basically working for you
guys if you succeed i succeed so what do
you need for me
to succeed uh
and that's you know i think that makes
a whole uh difference
if you guys are you know
partners to the road and you help them
become better
um then it's it's it's a whole
uh it's a whole different story in terms
of motivation in terms of
of um you know how they grow if and if
you
really care about your employees you
want them to grow you want them to be
better
for themselves uh i think i think that
makes a change
very very cool like i can only imagine
what you're going to be doing in the
next 25 years i can't really imagine
because
i you know it's crazy you know the the
different jumps that you did and and
you know the different positions that
you've held and the the variety i think
it's just
so awesome and yeah and i'm sure that
you know in these 20 minutes really
scratched the surface of
of a little bit of the of the insights
you've gained over the of these past 25
years really
and but i really appreciate you coming
here and and i really enjoyed this
conversation
i have a few questions not about your
work and not about marketing or
revenues it's more about tal are you
ready for them
yeah all right we'll go back to middle
school or high school
what was your favorite subject already
back then
uh science
any specific part of science no i just
love science in biology
science and biology wonderful somebody
in this world that inspires you along
your journey
somebody that you know role model or
even a little bit of inspiration
um
so i have so many people that throughout
my journey
you know help me i think
you know my first at my really first big
job
at american media uh i once
screwed up so badly i accidentally
sent a newsletter where all the
customers
worth can actually see all the emails
really and
i i i went to my boss then
and said you know what i i resigned
because i did
such a bad thing and he said
why are you resigning you know only if
you try
you make mistake wow so the fact that
you made a mistake means
you did something you did something good
and i really
you know i really appreciate that 20
something years after that
uh and made an amazing lesson
i i love that that's that's a really
really cool story thank you for sharing
that
and what are three words that you would
use to describe yourself
three words um
creative
self-driven
um
and a father wonderful creative
self-driven father
thank you very very much thank you no i
would say good luck on the rest of the
journey but i don't think
i think it's way beyond luck at this
point but thank you for taking the time
i
appreciate that i really appreciate it
and stay safe and stay healthy
thank you and thank you all the kind
words thank you